two
oh hello
off the rails
let's get into it
whoa
[Music]
that keemstar sound bite was pretty
seamless
fantastic that felt nice that felt right
[Music]
yeah it was great welcome to off the
rails guys we got a great one here today
sponsored by hellofresh
kamik kemikoto
policy genius and liquid iv we love you
guys thank you so much
dude today we have been planning this
segment for a while
for those of you who
do know about the show silent library
we are doing our own version of silent
library
and i think the challenges we have
planned sound like more fear factor
based than silent library like this [ __ ]
is kind of gnarly
that it's similar to the original silent
library not the mtv version like the the
japanese one right where where you get
thrown in lava yeah exactly no mercy
yeah so we are after the break we're
going straight to silent library there's
cash prizes to incentivize these guys to
torture themselves i'll be there of
course torturing myself for free
no instead of for me
i mean it's my show so that's the
incentive i guess but
just being technical here
but um it is gonna be insane and let me
just put it this way we all have our own
puke bucket
we're not sharing a puke bucket right
oh you didn't want to a few of us might
get a little i'm not stu going i was
just i was saying guys
if puking is likely i'm not i can't if
somebody's puked in a bucket i'm not i
can't do that i can't do that well
perfect so then you won't puke
i'm gonna puke on you i'm coming for you
do you understand me
living in your lap olivia's worried she
says her biggest fear
is puke you have a puke phobia i hate
people well yeah everyone hates puke you
know no like i can't be there i can't
see it oh you can't be around it i cover
my ears like that one time we had the
fart spray and ian ran to the bathroom i
covered my ears and what happens if you
listen do you get nauseous yes oh you
puke
i don't
well i always excuse myself before so i
don't know i should i'm just scared of
it
have you puked before yes absolutely
yeah okay
and she will today
oh ela hasn't puked right he has never
puked in her whole life that's crazy
lucky
don't buy it i'm telling you
i didn't buy it at first either
and now i've been with her long enough
to know that she's 100 percent telling
the truth
she's not lying should we get her over
here for silent library oh
she wouldn't puke but she wouldn't she
she would not debase herself to this
[ __ ]
she wouldn't even entertain the notion
oh there it is
so um
we got some great memes from the
subreddit to kick it off i gotta debate
this
ethan klein's the kind of guy who takes
his mcdonald's
home and pours his fries out onto a
plate
what does that say yeah but by the way i
just want to say for the record that is
not true
yeah you eat them on the way home i [ __ ]
i don't hesitate
i mean my hand's in the bag second one
right yeah
am i this guy i kind of feel like i
maybe have seen you do that
what well maybe for the show i've never
done that my life that was my thought
yeah for the show
but you really think i'd do that
ethan is more of a fry's won't survive
the trip home kind of guy yeah yeah
right
that's the top comment yeah
someone finally knows me yeah
uh yeah this one is pretty funny but uh
someone someone took this personally is
this bad
it's not bad it's just a specific kind
of person but i'm not that guy
i feel like oh whoop yeah not that guy
pal
i feel like um
someone who takes their fries home and
has the patience to pour it on a plate
out and eat it like a meal i mean that's
a really put together
person with a lot of self-control
that's not me
that's psycho [ __ ]
it i'm not going to insult our
friends there could be people that do
that that's charles manson [ __ ]
trust me you're not that guy but i i'm
definitely not that guy though because
also you want to get it hot i mean you
watch lukewarm fries for mcdonald's this
weekend had ten thousand likes
it defeats
the point of the experience of going to
mcdonald's yes somebody tweeted this out
and people were just like yeah
like what did i do to deserve this tweet
you're not that guy pal trust me
there was another one
i actually enjoyed this one
far more ethan is busted oh no another
one here another tweet
um everybody's making assumptions about
who i am
ethan klein the kind of guy to wiggle
his finger at a play to donuts and say
don't mind if i do okay ethan
i i have seen you do that
100
saying i don't mind if i do oh don't
mind if i do
i've never done this
but i'll eat the [ __ ] donut we used
to bring donuts into the office in the
mornings fairly often remember ian used
to grab him on the way in
and you would get very delighted when
you'd see oh it gets oh yeah and um yes
there may have been some some finger
wiggling going on ethan klein is is
damaging everything oh great making it
all out fools dog piling i think it's
more like when i see donuts i go who
brought this in
ah and i go like [ __ ] you and then i eat
a bunch of them right there i get mad
i've seen that reaction this guy is a
manipulative lying cop oh shut up it's
just donuts tim paul it's not that
[ __ ] serious
take your stupid garbage games oh my god
somewhere else and get out so angry
we're just talking about donuts man
and then also since it's exposed ethan
episode someone apparently got some cctv
footage
of the denny's where i apparently passed
gas uh oh
so
oh that's
that's pretty impressive slam dunk right
there this guy works for the nsa
apparently
no but no green cloud so where's the
proof that i farted huh right no well
but you were denying being there in the
first place well now that brings all of
your denials well you can't see maybe
ella's sitting next to me too
that you conveniently cut out this part
interesting interesting i mean that does
appear to be a late night empty denny's
wow yeah well ela was sitting with me so
yeah it's really good this guy's
tripping
yeah
yeah so i'm fully exposed
and actually speaking of exposed this is
really interesting we had a very
controversial call last week or yes or
on monday
uh some girl called in claiming that
her grandma
used to be a client of my mom's
in mexico when they lived there
and she said that her grandma
claimed that they moved to mexico to
escape their in their
children
they're annoying needy children yeah
yeah always asking for money
and to be honest with you
my mom would never i i immediately was
like my mom would only say nice things
about her about us because
she likes to brag about her kids sure i
guess normal moms do
but my mom in particular
like my mom would like build any stupid
achievement into like something to brag
about like
yeah like i failed out of college the
fourth year and did a fifth year my mom
would be like he's doing an extra year
of college she's so
so good such a good student he wanted to
spend extra time there
well anyway somebody
dug up some really compelling evidence
that this girl was lying
this
what appears to be the same exact girl
called in to say she saw zack's [ __ ]
and we immediately called caught her on
the lie
absolutely so here listen to this this
is is this the same voice
ollie are you there yes i am okay
okay yeah i will say i don't feel
comfortable yeah so my grandma told me
this part is off the record i've been
hanging on to this since august okay
excuse me zach i did not see you poop
because my grandma has had a second home
in ajijic my entire life
i know that i walked out the next that's
the same person right sure sounds like
it like
sure sounds like it but what's
incredible to me
i'm kind of impressed by the lengths
that this is that
we asked her some really tough questions
to verify her identity on the on the
mexico story
that she was able to verify i mean okay
she had to know my parents lived in
ajijic i don't remember where i've ever
i mentioned that it was mentioned on
family i think i think on families yeah
okay did we mention that she used to cut
hair there yeah well you mentioned that
she cuts hair i don't know if it was in
mexico i don't know if you guys said in
mexico but
and then also she like knew the
geographical like the well that's the
part that i mean all you need is
wikipedia to uh i think that's shown in
this video
right they show the wikipedia article
because she didn't know the first answer
and then and then she mentioned
and that i was like what okay wait you
let me google
um
um ajijic
mexico and see what you would have seen
it's a town
so you would see a picture with
mountains and and it says in a lake and
lake
it says lake surrounded by mountains
yeah she got there's no such thing as
the coincidence
[Music]
good troll though
she she was so convincing too and she
had the fake text messages from her
he went through some lengths for that
grandma
that's a that's a legit ass troll right
there
she also must have changed her number
because the program we use it shows
previous descriptions yeah and how many
times they called last who is this girl
what is she like [ __ ] from the cia
i guarantee you she's going to have like
a compilation of trolling the h3 podcast
she might be working on a little project
i mean i'm not mad at it i appreciate it
i actually
i'm impressed i'm impressed as well but
i want to
hmm
she's gonna have to disguise her voice
next time because we're holding her
a big why
has she ever got one past us so we
didn't realize
i mean
i can't think of another call that had
that like extreme of a of an accusation
also it is kind of [ __ ] up to make up
a lie that my mom hates her children i
mean that is yeah yeah
it's a little bit but maybe she's
surprised at how far it went
i mean in her defense when we were first
reading anything was that bad i just
thought it was like small talk taken out
of context but dude she said mike
everybody used to gossip how much they
hate their kids
yeah i guess that's pretty mean-spirited
but you gotta respect the troll i do i
do respect the troll yeah
all right well uh whoever you are you
can either come clean or try again but
we're on to you we do a little trolling
it's called we do it you can call in and
discuss if you want if you want to come
clean now we like to troll or i mean on
monday yup or friday
all right guys up next before look at
this we talked about it
we got it
you know we i'm obsessed with trying
these stupid fast food treads
the chase hudson meal
this box looks like a doo-doo house
it's a house made of duties look at it
just cause it's brown yeah
yeah i guess that's not the most i mean
you could appeal in color more colors
than [ __ ] brown what mega doo-doo
[Laughter]
do people people know him as chase
hudson
or do people just know him as little
hoodie i believe little huddy has his
own burger king meal like i was saying i
mean he's
not that famous
you keep saying that well i mean i'm the
wrong person to say this because i i
literally didn't know who i mean
he's famous with i guess young kids got
12 million instagram followers i mean
he's famous he's hit like mainstream i'm
pretty sure no he he just he he's
performing with machine gun kelly well
dude machine gun kelly's the type of
dude that's tour with little huddy what
that's true proving more and more what a
[ __ ] tool he is nothing wrong with
little huddy music i'm not familiar with
it but machine gun kelly you i mean have
some respect for yourself he's peak
cringe for sure he had bro
that video of him like rocking out on
the table yeah the exact board nevermind
or whatever it's just never forgetty
never forgetting rest in spaghetti
um could someone bring me a water had to
forfeit mine to the dogs
yeah thank you
so
i i don't know and maybe i'm wrong but
like like he has like how many on on
tick tock little huds
is that his fans the little hoods a
little hut the little pizza hut little
hottie tick tock let's see like 40
million i mean emilio has like 120 she's
on another stratosphere 32 million 32 i
mean you know why are we he it's 32
million people follow him and you're
trying to argue he's not famous that's a
lot of people i feel like i'm just
saying burger king meal i don't get it
when i think of bts bts had a mcdonald's
meal when i think of the most famous
people from tiktok on like that side no
i do i think addison ray charlie demilio
lil hubby i'm i'm with her on that if
you ask me little huddy if you ask me
who are the biggest male tick talkers
he's the first name that comes i would
think noah beck i see that he was the
first one i knew of yeah i knew him way
before good morning my queens of
tick-tock is that what he does on
tick-tock
wait what does a little huddy even do on
tick-tock does he just thirst trap
he was like sort of like an android made
out of tick-tock like he was making
musically like he was
he's like thank you musically yeah wow
so he he lives this [ __ ] he grew up in
this show exactly he's like you know
michael jackson was
i'm sorry but this dude has a video with
half a million views now that may seem
like a lot but if you're the biggest
dude on tick tock from three days ago yo
come on you can't be having 300 500 000
view tick tocks from three days ago and
be that famous wow you're right no
seriously
you fell off plus ratio no hold on hold
on i'm making it i'm making a good point
look this one has 400 000 views 50 000
likes from four days ago that might seem
like a lot that's like what i get on a
bad post you know what i'm saying and i
have
not 32 million if you go to charlie
dimiglio
the uh emilio
tick talk
roll it
okay
you're going to see what the real star
power is she doesn't get below
like 10 million per that's real [ __ ]
right there
yeah well maybe he fell off then he did
fall off plush ratio but now he has a
burger king meal well
look at ninja that [ __ ] gets a
thousand streams and he's still getting
like brand deals bye-bye i'm sure he's
still doing okay he's got that name
power
he's a little huddy okay well let's see
what little huddy i literally didn't
know who little hottie was until do you
want a minute at the spelling point i
just seem like a douche um
both can be true not a douche i'd say
more of a boomer
he gets 500 000 views per video that's
not falling off i i
i mean that's the other factor is that's
just one video right women not a point
you got a point it's like a valid
argument i guess no demilio doesn't get
under 10
wake up maybe okay
didn't burger king also kind of fall off
burger king was never on yeah exactly
exactly
there you go falling
off ratio
all right so here's the little honey
okay boomer maybe this will revive his
career
3 000 calorie
wait wasn't this supposed to be
something special it's just a spicy
chicken sandwich yeah no i don't think
it's special
i mean two pickles in the middle
are don't you want a pickle on every
bite or is that no that's too much
pickle oh really yeah no it's like a
little it's a little surprise halfway
through
[Music]
welcome to the chew zone baby
[Music]
you guys don't have to zoom on my mouth
it's close what do you mean
[Music]
hut
thank you baby
but no there's supposed to be cheese on
it a little hutty i think there was it
just doesn't look as appealing no
there's no cheese on this oh they [ __ ]
it up there's no [ __ ] cheese on this
little honey meal look at this wow there
was supposed to be cheese on this
[ __ ] well then this isn't an
official little hottie meal this is just
a normal this is
that this bootleg with some bootleg
[Music]
and that's [ __ ] mozzarella
so i tried one of those mozzarella
sticks
i gotta say it's hard to [ __ ] up
mozzarella sticks and burger king has
found a way
and then this whatever the [ __ ] this is
this uncalled the chocolate shake i
think
yeah
this mysterious substance
fair enough sometimes you don't get what
you [ __ ] deserve
this is this had like 3 000 calories the
total meal yeah this is probably half of
it yeah easily eat easily
i can't do that what are we going to say
b saying how you feeling do you feel hip
i feel like i
i'm [ __ ] furious that they did all
this and didn't even put cheese on it
[Music]
ethan
that's too large of a bite
[Music]
why did you do this
to yourself what are you doing you're
like your keys on
[Music]
i feel like ila would want me to step in
at this point oh yeah set it aside we're
done oh oh come on you guys do want me
to do it how's that olivia bro we're
about to see much worse
the little hoodie is not it that was not
that you know by any stretch
nope
no cheese though that's what makes the
little honey meals a little honey meal
[Applause]
i feel like the mott's sticks on the
side was the unique element here
compared to compared to like the bts
meal which was just like
the [ __ ]
chicken nuggies and some fries and a
soda
it's pretty standard or standard meal
right that was the worst celebrity meal
the sauces were good though
no no no bk i like the the there's i was
saying the little hoodie is though oh
that's the worst the worst yeah i'd
argue the box makes it the mail
and that's it
but the box is disgusting
this is the worst box i've ever seen too
just brown the [ __ ] house with full of
[ __ ]
okay oh i forgot
our food keeps it so real little huddy
had to use his real name to tell you
about it
oh that's why it's not the little honey
it's a big branding thing he's no longer
low huddy he's chase
hudson he's coming out now
when shannon went to go pick up the meal
none of the workers knew who little
hoodie was she had to say chase hudson
and i wonder the nelly meal the cornell
haines jr meal if that causes confusion
as well
first of all nobody knows who little
huddy is period that's my point
none of them knew who the [ __ ] that guy
was because he's not famous
they only know chase hudson because
they've been trained they have a chase
hudson meal and we're the first person
to ever ask for it
[Music]
from death to life
i'm pretty sure they were sold out at
the first place that she went
am i wrong shannon was it sold out
they didn't have oh they just didn't
they just are like why should we ship
this out to every location it doesn't
make sense yeah exactly
shannon said can i get so did you order
the chase hudson or the lol how do you
go ahead
this is shannon my assistant
face reveal
um yeah i wanted to [ __ ] that can i
please have a chase hudson meal and
they're like what i was like a little
honey meal and they're like i'm sorry
and i was like do you know what i'm
talking about and they're like no um so
i went to another location asked them if
they had it they said no i said can i
just get the stuff in the box and said
yeah and then they handed me the actual
box because you're the first person that
ordered it they didn't even know they
had it i guess i had to be the guinea
pig for them
but oh so you ordered the stuff dude
nobody's buying this we're the first
person i guess i guess they literally
just have
a room in the back full of chase hudson
boxes yeah i just stacked well we
secured the bag so that's all that
matters so did they
yeah good job by the way securing the
bag
did um did you did they give you the
food separately or in the box no so i
asked them they're like we don't have it
and they gave it to me in the box and i
said oh so you do have it and they're
just like
we don't want anything about anything
but we got it done that's all that
matters minimum wage when i work at
burger king
all right happy to have you happy to
help you got it you did it
shannon ladies and gentlemen i think
they just
didn't expect anyone to buy it honestly
they just wanted to have it on their
website
i refuse to acknowledge chase hudson as
famous uh cam uh found the commercial
for it and he said it's worth checking
out it's in this oh yeah
i mean we're in too deep at this point
now
been talking about a little huddy's meal
for 30 minutes now so
might as well go all the way
oh he's in a car with himself
okay guys
12 000 views cooking banned 120
artificial ingredients from its food
that's why my meal
what the [ __ ] you say
i can't ban a 120
what's he say
cooking ban
120 artificial ingredients from its food
that's why my meal keeps you real
actually
dude it's the chase hudson meal huh bk
dropped hoodie and chose the re huh
i need a crit
i i was listening really carefully i i
can't tell you what he said it's cut off
they're trashing someone else's food and
saying oh they have 120 artificial
ingredients but by the way he said
that's why ours keeps it real he didn't
say how many artificial ingredients
theirs has probably a hundred
that's why we keep it real
he's like ours we have 500 but keeping
it real exactly
they should have told him to enunciate
and yeah he's not done another day
open your mouth when you speak
sir guys
olivia who the [ __ ] are you
to direct little hudson oh my god i'm so
sorry this is the a-list celebrity here
this you're right this says swagger you
are right
he's speaking huda knees
yeah true who didn't even
ease
120 artificial ingredients from its food
that's why my meal keeps cereal
huh
[Laughter]
the guy on the left is little hoodie the
right is chase hudson oh okay
interesting it's like a dr jekyll mr
hyde yeah
one gets burger with this cheese one
without
bk dropped hoodie and chose the real you
to create this meal but i'm the real man
don't take it personally
you could have really used some lips the
teeth the tip of the tongue
red leather yellow leather
120 artificial ingredients from its food
that's why my meal that's my mother
dude it's the chase hudson meal huh bk
dropped hoodie and chose the real you to
create
don't take it personal you're just my
celebrity persona wait i'm feeling good
oh so this is che this is chase hudson
um he wears a flannel
he's down to earth he's more related by
the way this is a low budget
[ __ ] commercial i'm just
telling you this is like the lowest
budget possible
shows were pretty big with gen z oh
hey
try the chase hudson meal food so burger
king had little honey put his real name
on it love your new song dude that was
so sweet of you man
king banda dude
yeah there you go you don't have to
think about it dude
there you have it
no one would agree to work with them
they're like [ __ ] i just put them in
twice
well i think their marketing budget was
probably 500
you know
a dollar for each ingredient
all right
well there you have it guys the honey
meal so run out to your
nearest burger king and get your hands
on one before they're sold out
[Applause]
should i open this how long have you
been going because i've got this special
pack of cards i want to open before
silent library too um let's do
it now's the time
do i need a so you guys heard about this
um
[Music]
mischief yeah i don't think we talked
about it on the show you should oh i
never showed the cards yeah you did oh
did we oh we did yeah so we showed the
cards that's right where it had like
trap trash
trasha
trisha trasher yeah there was the james
charles getting his ass waxed
david dobrik running over jeff in a
tractor
mutilating him and um
what was the other one
oh yeah jake paul just being a goon yeah
so this was made by these guys mischief
and they are the ones that made little
nas's blood shoes
they're like an artist collective that
makes it's funny on the back of the pack
i don't know if you can see it
it says
they're half fraud and have
fun i guess that's their thing that's
not fraud
that's fraud
so
let's open it let's see uh let's see
what we got hopefully i got some rare
apparently there's hundreds of different
ones so i'm actually really interested i
wonder if these are valuable because
it's like they sold out immediately
and they are collectibles these guys
that they make [ __ ] yeah is your hands
covered in a little hoodie well hold on
no but the pack is like not made to open
easy so i'm afraid i'm going to damage
them uh do you want a pair of scissors
yeah because th this is actually can you
grab
olivia's grip i'm going to get these
graded and framed and everything
yeah so if you guys are interested in
whatever miss jiff is up to
i think they're on twitter i don't think
they have it
i mean they have a twitter and instagram
just m s c
h they're on instagram oh instagram okay
how many followers they have on
instagram
more than a little hoodie probably thank
you
all right
here we go
beautiful
all right guys this is huge
oh i got i got garbage fall that's got
to be a good one
a rare find
garbage pail influencer jerk paul we got
that
sweet
that's awesome we got a doberg dude wait
i got a dobrik as well yeah wait oh it's
only these four i thought they said
there was hundreds of them do brick
well maybe you know
david dubrick running over jeff whittick
and a
excavator so violent
david dumbrick
if he's really showing off his shaky
are your hands so shaky they're always
but today i had coffee so like they're
extra
let me see
go show trash patricia
trasha paytas bro you have the shake
you're like shaking hands searching for
stabilized now they're stabilized isn't
there a way to stabilize the phone yeah
i could just put it down
yeah just put it down while you're
holding it yeah the only person i've
seen has worse hands is ian
all right here okay
try that
i'll just show him here
oh beautiful that's not bad actually
actually much better
jerk ball
i thought there i really i'm a little
disappointed because i thought there was
more unless they gave me a rigged pack
they might have
because then i'm down it's promotional
if it's a rigged pack then i'm down
right
oh what it says [ __ ] h3 on it i didn't
you didn't notice that
no oh yeah that's one of the best parts
oh wow it's like a direct shout out
that's awesome
and i'll just let her there's chicken
nuggets
oh i'm gonna let this one sit for a
little extra
this is the charizard
this is the charm
and then of course james charles um why
was there a what was the krispy kreme i
was seeing
what there was some story about how he
has his assistant shave his ass right
uh yeah
yeah somebody that worked for him came
out and claimed that was one of the
things she had true she had to do for
him jack asked him this is such a great
illustration i love the art yeah
you're saying there's a krispy kreme
element to trisha's that we missed trash
i mean no when he was
didn't it did anybody else see that
there was a krispy kreme thing on your
desk
it might be the back of one of those oh
in the pack this came in the pack oh
it's just a krispy kremes donut
gift card with no
oh well there you go get yourself some
krispy kremes
maybe just to keep it it's probably to
keep it from
bending okay
it's very odd
keep it crispy well listen it's all this
is all hand done by the collective so
it's kind of clever i mean
it keeps the pack
i get the idea i just don't
know why they would use it so let's get
this framed
i want to get these framed and rated you
guys okay
yeah
i guess
hopefully uh psa is uh back open you
know
yeah probably not right and thank you
are they taking submissions now that was
fantastic well shout out to mischief
uh for sending those really appreciate
it those guys are always up to something
really cool what where do you should
they be followed on instagram
shout out to mischief on instagram
msca it literally says do not follow us
in their description or their bio wait
there's only one post
yeah i think they swap it out when they
have new drops
oh these guys are so interesting they're
so like artsy spooky yeah it says do not
follow us so um well [ __ ] you wait
followed by 908 and what the [ __ ] you
did yo what the [ __ ] you did exactly
what they said not to do i'm kidding i
blew it
yeah
i'm gonna actually i want to do a fake
opening for tick tock i'm gonna do that
later be [ __ ] a shot
let's see oh uh cam just linked
stockx
uh a booster pack is
uh about 50 bucks
so we got to get that up there before i
on these off
sign them
i feel like the youtube [ __ ] is just not
that valuable it's like youtube [ __ ] is
just
nobody wants a pass you know james
charles is like david dobrik
trasha is these people going to be
around in
10 years maybe sister
[Laughter]
um all right well we've got a bunch of
other great stories but we should just
get help we've been about 30 minutes
right yes all right so let's just get
right to the silent library that
everybody
is anticipating i am excited and also
scared to proceed but let's do it
so uh quick commercial break and then
silent library time to take a short
break thank you rudy
kami koto
[Music]
y'all should be scared because i got a
box of knives here boy look at this this
is the real deal
kamikoto knives
japanese
steel knives made using traditional
techniques from japan
certificate of authenticity this is the
real deal here guys
um
they tap into more than 800 years of
traditional technique from hansu japan
it's a layer distinctive layered pattern
of iron working sword smithing and metal
casting to create the special sharp
single beveled
knife
wow
they only use steel source from mills in
japan
this is
beautiful
man it's a got a nice weight to it too
all right
yeah definitely
i tried them out made a meal the other
night uh using them and i was very
impressed and the nicest knife i ever
used
dude this thing's sick which one did you
use like the pairing knife or like
veggies i actually used the the i
the cleaver
oh you used the cleaver i did
because this seems like for me
what'd you cut with it uh not meat i cut
uh zucchinis and a few other things but
um
maybe that's not the proper use of it
but i'm not a knees i would probably
train chef so
i'm yeah probably that would have been
the right choice it just looks so cool
it does look awesome this one is pretty
safe got such a great weight listen let
me tell you about this
use only source to steal from japan
japanese steel
and um
these are the japanese steel high
quality product that you all expect
each blade is crafted using techniques
that have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy duty ash box
as you guys have seen
uh make sure the it makes sure the
knives are stored safely it also makes
kami uh kemikoto a great gift because
the wooden box they're presented are so
beautiful their products range uh in
vast array of japanese steel knife such
as a three piece
kampeki knife set i think that's what we
have here or you can get a vegetable
knife set of seven inches long hello the
slicing knife
eight and a half inches long and the
utility knife five inches long and the
kamikoto is sanaku blade
sentaku
and the samurai sword as well for
slaying enemies
just kidding that'll kill samurai sword
that i know
all blades are handled with a satin
finish for a subtle yet stunning luster
each kamikoto knife goes through a
rigorous 19-step process that takes
several years from start to finish to
complete are you serious yeah man i
gotta get these home and give these a
shot
this is so nice
with more than 100 years of experience
between the bladesmiths
uh their shaping raw steel
polishing sharpening excruciatingly fine
edge
each knife is individually inspected
kamida ko kamikoto is so confident about
their knives that each knife comes with
a lifetime guarantee
and because of the single beveled edge
kamikoto knives can achieve an
unbelievably sharp edge you can't get
with other knives
this is going to be one of those knives
where you can like shave a grape super
thin without trying
you should have some grapes shape some
crepes baby
you can maintain the edge of your blade
with one of kamikoto's sharpening wet
stones kamikoto knives are used by
several chefs working at michelin
restaurants that's badass
um kamikoto appreciates that a good
product is incomplete without great
service they work hard
not only on their crop craftsmanship and
flawless blades but they understand the
client's needs uh to integral the the
blade is integral to the japanese spirit
of omo
tenashi the philosophy of helpless
selfless hospitality
i'll be i'm not making this for anyone
but myself go to camikoto.com
h3 in the description
that's
m i k o t o
dot com slash h3 pretty cool i'm excited
to get home and try these
so yeah check them out these are really
cool knives if you're in the market
camikoto.com h3
compared to pumpkin patch photoshops and
costume planning shopping for life
insurance with policy genius can be one
of the easiest tasks on your october to
do list
why is that because policy genius makes
it so flippant easy to compare quotes
from over a dozen top insurers all in
one place why should you be comparing
well let me tell you you could be saving
50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius you
could also be saving
thirteen hundred dollars or more per
year on life insurance by comparing
insurances using policy
genius the licensed expert at policy
genius work for you not the insurance
company so you can trust them to help
you navigate every step of the shopping
and buying process that kind of service
has earned policy genius thousands of
five-star reviews across trustpilot and
google and eligible applicants can get
covered in as little as a week thanks to
an award-winning policy option that
swaps the standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call
there's a reason why policy genius was
rated number one by forbes advisor
higher than the other
pieces of [ __ ] uh competitors that i
can't say their names properly
bladder
ethos and
bestow these nuts on your mouth
did i say it right you did but i don't
know
about the nuts part well i'm just saying
they're crap policy genius is everything
getting started is easy head to
policygenius.com h3podcast in minutes
you can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and scheduling
for free policy genius doesn't add on
extra fees either so head to
policygenius.com
h3 podcast right now that's policy
genius because when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right
hello fresh guys
you want to cook a delicious healthy
nutritious home-cooked meal but you
don't want to fuss with going to the
grocery store
you know getting all the right portions
you gotta drive you gotta come back you
buy too much stuff what do you do
hello fresh
takes the hassle out of home cooking
it's affordable it's fun it's easy
that's why it's america's number one
meal kit
fall is busy time but hello fresh
recipes save time you'd otherwise spend
meal planning shopping chopping
and you get back what matters which is
time of course
and uh the fall harvest is officially on
with hellofresh count on seasonal
recipes like pumpkin cinnamon rolls
and thanksgiving ready sides as well as
fresh high quality ingredients to travel
from the farm to your front door in less
than a week yeah i mean i love hello
fresh everyone that tries it loves it
because the food is always so good
so fresh
they deliver it in a
like refrigerated box so it always stays
fresh yep they send you a beautiful
recipe and card with all the about all
the food and how to cook it i mean it's
the greatest
i'll never get tired of abe's burrito we
have all the guys take turns cooking the
hell of freshers and taking photos and
this was av's photo for us so
i mean it looks good it's just it's just
funny
it was really good i have no information
about it it was it was good that's all
you need to know ian actually look at
that look at now that's a that's a bowl
of food right there boy
everybody loves hello fresh it's super
fun if you're not good at cooking or if
you're good at cooking it's kind of fun
either way but
if you don't usually cook this is a
really fun inviting way to get into it
and you end up with some really
delicious food i didn't cook before uh i
mean this basically taught me how to
cook
really i mean i you know that's really
yeah because i mean listen if you don't
understand a lot of the concepts of
cooking just timing and everything and
and yeah no i mean
i've been doing it for about a year now
i actually learned some stuff from hella
fresh too absolutely i got some meat i
think it was a steak and they said make
sure to dry it off you have to dry it
perfectly and i actually that's how you
get a great sear on meat is that there
can't be any moisture water or moisture
on the surface and i learned that from
hellofresh and i do that whenever i cook
meat now there you go
that's true
we love it
go to hellofresh.com h314
and use code h314 for up to 14 free
meals including free shipping
that's hellofresh.com h314 use code h314
for up to 14
free meals including free shipping guys
and remember there's a reason why hello
fresh is amir america's number one meal
kit it's because it slaps every time
liquid iv i love liquid iv because
what's not to love it tastes great
there's all these different like
purposes and flavors they've got one
that's got caffeine in it i don't
sometimes i can't drink coffee i have a
sensitive stomach and i'll get back a
liquid iv if i need a boost in the
morning and what's great about the
liquid iv
is that
first of all it
hydrates faster
and more efficiently than water alone it
contains five essential vitamins more
than vitamin vitamin c than an orange as
much potassium as a banana it's
healthier than sugary sports drinks it's
got no artificial flavors or
preservatives it's got less sugar than
an apple it's made with clean
ingredients non-gmo vegan and free of
gluten dairy and soy
they've got this special
cellular transport technology that helps
you know
rehydrate quickly go ahead dan which
flavor you got there
we're rocking with the passion fruit
today what's the hydration hydration
multiplier
let's go
jug with some water get hydrated
yeah um they got the optimum ratio of
glucose sodium potassium
right into your bloodstream
yep there you go they've they're also
good guys they donated 4 million
servings in response to covid19 products
are being donated to hospitals first
responders food banks veterans and
active military
they've donated over 11 million servings
globally
yeah they've got one that's like for
immune boost they've got one for
caffeine they've got one for hydrate and
all kinds of different flavors and kind
of purposes there grab your favorite
liquid iv flavors nationwide at walmart
oh my god they switched they used to be
costco
they switched to walmart or walmart now
all right
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use code h3 at
checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you get better hydration
today using the promo code h3 at
liquidivy.com
okay guys
here we are in silent library
um
i've decided to put up
there's 14 rounds
i'm going to be putting up 200 per round
potential if we clear every round
obviously i'm not going to pay myself
but you all guys stand to make about 600
bucks a piece
serious money
i wish someone would sponsor so i could
put up like real money so that get you
guys to do weird [ __ ] but that's the
best i can do for you
i kind of appreciate it so the rules are
um
we're gonna draw
something to do it right
we're all gonna flip a card one of these
has a death card
if you get the death card you pull a
challenge
so if you pull a challenge that you
absolutely don't want to do
each person gets one pass
where they can pick
some other person to do it
you'll notice here the decibel counter
if it passes 75
decibels it'll beep and we've failed the
challenge and the money is lost
but rest assured i'm not here to
sabotage i am on your team even though
i lose money when you guys win that's
okay
all right so uh who goes first so we all
all right wait all right
yeah okay in three two one
so olivia's been going on about how she
has a puke
but one other thing
we all have cute legs
yeah it's gonna get pretty bad
all right olivia
what you got
donut roulette
interesting
so our librarian is gonna bring out
this temple
sam is our librarian here too
she'll be bringing out each
challenge
quite a loud
the librarian is gonna blow this forever
take a big bite
oh
there was mayonnaise
so that's 200 on the scoreboard
it's worse the sriracha the mayonnaise
grab some blood
for the record
if olivia pulled this
we would not of course do this
okay
okay this is exciting
for me are you doing a little chess what
are you doing
what are you gonna take your shirt
don't worry you're gonna see me
you can exercise him right i stopped
like two weeks ago
what could you start doing
oh something fell off
oh is it safety
wait can i see
oh my god
all right love kick it
drive drive love right
[Applause]
okay so i think we're we're
judging that a w because
what set the alarm off was the clamp
heading hitting love
how was that
new fetish
yeah
the first clamp really hurt because it
didn't have a little safety
all right well that's 400 bucks
i'm back
there you go
wait already you guys are already
getting like 100 a piece you'll be broke
by into this
okay we turned
we turned it down to 70 because we
determined that
75 was
too
high
so more challenging now
read it
it says cake up that dough
that's fine we were trying to get [ __ ]
on your head for years bro
what does that mean
the librarian is coming back
oh sh
is that frosty yeah
i'll gladly take that off your dome
that was closed that was 68.
okay so who wants to decorate dancing
like a cupcake
i'm interested
pull that over
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
just pretend you're [ __ ] blowing
your hair
this is awesome
how's it gonna get this one
that's a good question
what else we got should we get the back
in there
that looks pretty good actually
it almost ate seven
[Applause]
that was too much
exhale man how you chewing i think
there's still frosting in my ear
is that not even kidding zach will look
it out for you
okay
i i gotta say there's three left and i'm
feeling scared because those ones
were not the ones i was scared of
so i'm getting nervous
let's see what happens okay three two
one
yes
[Applause]
oh
it probably tastes better this way
that's so vile why did you even do that
what's his idea
that's [ __ ] up
yeah do that right
do that for the camera
okay
oh my god are you serious that's what it
looks like
okay stop worrying
let me smell it what is it blending
interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
with pickles
is
there's people starving across the world
you're not gonna drink this beautiful
little honey meals
amy what's wrong with this
there's people starving out there you
she didn't blend it up a lot for you
face the camera
[Applause]
it's not bad
we already failed
no way that's not bad
i like the chewy drink texture
apparently
and she panicked the wrong cameras
i want to try
if you finish that you will go to a
happy place yes just close your eyes
your ears
[Music]
do it
oh
mustache
zach is just willingly kicking down the
muddy money go for his stupid squad
kick back one more big one attack i'll
put it on the board
you know what it tastes like you know
when you go to a passover seder the
herosies it's got that same texture the
white doll roses you know
we've come so far
uh yeah you can throw it upstairs
[Applause]
do you know what a butterfly is
when someone kisses you with their
eyelash eyelashes
did you know
excuse me
that's what i'm saying
how do i have to do
is
yeah this is way of course for me i
would never do this with anyone you shot
someone's grass you freak
i don't have to do this
so
i don't like this this makes me very
uncomfortable i is the hr issue
did you consult with hr
as long as zac is up for it
you can send good luck at the camera
i zachary
you're not getting more than one
[Laughter]
go back to your seat
okay
don't look at me yeah don't ever sit by
me
so i was gonna say that
even though we failed that challenge
i felt like
it was still very hard
like there was a moment where we were
about to go in that was very
just like i love you but just going that
way you know
i felt violated
i was the one that consented here
all right here we go
is
can i
oh
[Applause]
it smells like blueberries
i really no it did smell it smells good
okay smell it
[Applause]
hello
[Applause]
that's too much
you're good
you're good you're done dude
um
the challenge is over
next one is a group challenge we're all
gonna do it is
[Applause]
yeah okay i think it's gonna be a spicy
challenge
i can't do this
i really like a pitcher
this is mad dog 357
the two first ingredients is reaper
scorpion and ghost pepper
it's a reaper i'm not trying to be funny
i'm so scared
i don't know why i did that
yeah
cheers
it doesn't taste good
bad flavor
very hot
water at the top that's really hot
be careful that's boring
just
[Music]
there's a piece of hot sauce
that's definitely like a top tier hot
sauce
my tongue is
my tongue is so hot
no
[Applause]
[Music]
wait okay here's the deal
here's the deal
that's a w obviously
that's a thousand on the board
i'll add another 500
a b
eats another knockout dude you can do it
come on 500 please
100
you can do it buddy
why you did this wrong
i feel massive right now this smells
like
it just soaked in that's all that's so
much more before
well it's a thousand bucks it's a lot of
money
doubling the price
i'm okay with
is
let me just make sure you're getting a
big advice like right to where the stick
hole is
oh man
it's not helping
you sure you want this
you don't have to do this
oh
[Applause]
i will say to amy's credit
that
all these guys were talking big game
and ain't reach none of them would do it
maybe
i'm so bad
you need more milk you gotta keep
drinking
oh
i think he needs a beer
no beers
no it's not
here we're not out
the carbonation is
horrible oh
he does
you floss
[Music]
how do you feel
well i'd say that's a w
how you oh
you feel better at bad stuff
[Applause]
we're gonna continue playing
oh you did good
good great work he's just
spitting
get ready
[Applause]
[Applause]
people usually have to pay for this much
feet
that was claws
okay
it doesn't hurt
you could see him sticking to his feet
i couldn't stick
[Applause]
three two one
[Applause]
candy apple crunch
that's nice it's candy what's wrong with
cali apple it's an onion
okay so it's a caramel onion
that's a lot of crunch
[Music]
jesus how is that it's not good
20 seconds
i would say the healthiest challenge
we've had today what is wrong with you
zach you keep complaining your stomach's
left
for the show i didn't ask you to do that
my eyes are watering
to do this i got my own [ __ ] to do
more butterflies
it's a beer bonk of gravy
i'll try it but i gotta do it you can't
do it nobody's feet so i feel like
wrong
i'm doing this to pay you guys doesn't
make any sense
no
it's like you can't say you don't have
to do it just a little bit just sit
right
[Music]
i spit on the top
still you didn't even lift it up
just take it away from me please
he's going for another one yeah you
gotta hit more if you want
come give me a castle
the cash prize is up to
2100
plus 500 rabies i'm sweating here yeah
i'm broke i'm safe
but that's not my turn
like fly adolf hitler so
we have like a fly hall's house here
every day at dan's hands the fly is
here and he wants to talk to you
get rid of that white spot damn that too
close
you failed
amazing
still
sounds sexy
so
can i get it off him is this an edible
wrong
who he wants to hear come on it's over
when i can see his nipples okay
this is this is worse than the butterfly
i guess
he wants to metabolize
all right
going through the wall
you can't lift it off this shirt
you can't use your hands bro
[Music]
we're running out of time
all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think it looks like he got one nipple
free but not the other one
sorry
you guys been wanting to do that for a
while
that was that was up here
go ahead
oh [ __ ]
wax
these [ __ ] almost hairless wait
you don't have any hair in it
yes beautiful why do you have hair
you have hair on your chest
you want to do it in your armpit all
right so i please have hair all right so
we brought lina in because nobody want
to touch avery's office
here we go
all right two one
it wasn't me
i think it was it was like a sound
and also you have a lot of hair left you
might have to get another one in there
what if we go again i'm telling you it
was the rip it wasn't me i don't think i
feel like it was the red there was no i
don't think it was the rip this was
oh yeah
there it is
[Music]
i tricked your ass
you got to do it on the other arm
because you were like primed up for that
one
things
[Music]
i think we have to do it again
all right call me though um
[Applause]
uh we have fifa fish in honor of our
dear above special delivery
i've heard about this it's apparently
the stinkiest
nastiest
food and this the swedes uh it's a
swedish delicacy people really
i think some people like it some people
don't like it but there's
there's a lot of people in sweden that
really [ __ ] with this fish
i smell these food it's
a hard candy
oh my god it's just a fish
oh
[Applause]
it's a whole different profile when you
get your nose up close
you get that it's like a whole different
profile
small feature
okay you have to get your nose
shredder
oh my
really
[Applause]
[Applause]
puppy
[Laughter]
oh my god
okay well that that was a fail that was
a hell dude no
so what's that final tally for
2 400 was
24 plus 500 i'm down 3 000 [ __ ]
dollars how much to eat a whole fish
a whole thing first
dip your finger in and smell your finger
because that's what i've been doing
to get used to it i'm telling you it's
like next
level how much
just dip your [ __ ] finger in bro
three thousand dollars dumb
oh you're smelly
dip your finger in hand
let's see it's like it's worse it's
different it's a different thing
it's like
you still eat that 500
[Applause]
that's what you said
you
no probably
oh what are you up there
that's an elephant
love is it safe if i eat this whole
thing
of course but i want you to know that no
one in sweden would ever eat that 500
eaten if i hold it down
500 if you can hold the whole thing down
the whole thing done
oh no the whole thing down bro tail and
everything how are you doing
i don't know the ian was this machine
he's praying to god he's looking to
heaven bro
he's asking jesus to let him live
[Applause]
i can't believe you've done this
fear
[Applause]
that [ __ ] is swimming in your
stomach right now
all right i'm broke that's the show
everything's over
i gotta get out of here i'm done
respect my respect we're done
[Music]